this is a painting of nicole ahram i
looked up the phonetic spelling before
making this video i'm assuming i'm still
mispronouncing it but and i print out i
apologize to all the french speakers out
there ahead of time but he was a famous
french philosopher mathematician who
lived in medieval france he lived in the
1300s and he's famous for his proof that
the harmonic series actually diverges
and just as a little bit of review this
is the harmonic series one plus one half
plus one third plus one fourth plus one
fifth and it's always been in my brain
the first time that i saw the harmonic
series it wasn't obvious to me whether
it converged or diverged it looks like
well gee you know all these terms are
positive but they're going towards zero
so i could imagine that that this thing
could converge but he proved otherwise
he proved one of the most famous and
most elegant proofs in mathematics that
it does indeed diverge
and the way that he did this is he
replaced every term in the harmonic
series
with a term that is less than or equal
to that term
and then if he proves and if he if he if
he if he and then by proving that his
new series diverges and is less than or
equal to this series or each of the
terms are less than or equal to each of
the corresponding terms of here then he
says therefore by the comparison test
this must diverge
so how did he construct that
well one way to think about it is he
replaced each of the terms in the
harmonic series with the largest power
of one half that is less than or equal
to that term
so what's the largest power of one half
that is less than or equal to one
well one is a power of one half so that
is one half to the zero power is one so
one is the largest power of one half
that is less than or equal to one so
i'll just write the one there
and now what's the largest power of
one-half that is less than or equal to
one-half well that's just going to be
one-half that's just one-half to the
first power
now what's the largest power of what's
the largest power of one-half that is
less than or equal to one-third
well one-half is larger than one-third
it's not less than one-third we want it
to be less than one-third so the next
power of one-half
is or i should say the power of one-half
the largest power of one-half that is
less than or equal to one-third is
one-fourth so replace one-third
with one-fourth and of course replace
one-fourth
with one-fourth
and then we get to one
and then we get to one-fifth
what's the largest power of one-half
that is less than or equal to one-fifth
and once again one-fourth is greater
than one-fifth the largest power of
one-half that is less than or equal to
one-fifth is
one-eighth so he replaced that
with one-eighth he of course replaces
for the same reason that with one-eighth
he would replace that one
with one-eighth and of course one-eighth
the largest the largest power of one of
one half that is less than or equal to
one-eighth is one-eighth and then what
would he replace one-ninth with
well he would replace one-ninth with 1
16 by the exact same argument and you'd
keep going all the way until you get to
1 16. so you would essentially have 8 1
16 in a row
well what's interesting here well for
let's first verify that we can we can
use the comparison test here so in this
first series each of the terms are
non-negative in the second series each
of the terms are non-negative
and we also see that each of the
corresponding terms in a harmonic series
is larger than each of the or the
greater than or equal to the
corresponding terms in this years we
constructed it this way these are equal
this one is equal this is greater than
this one-third is greater than
one-fourth one-fourth is equal to
one-fourth one-fifth is greater than
one-eighth one-sixth is greater than
one-eighth one-seventh is greater than
one-eighth one-eighth is equal to 1 8.
and so one way to think about it is this
is the each of the corresponding terms
in this new constructed series are
smaller and let me just call it s
in this
infinite sum and of course we keep going
on and on and on maybe i should do that
in magenta
so we see that each of the corresponding
terms here are smaller than the
corresponding terms up here and they're
all positive so if we can prove
if we can prove that s that this sum
right over here diverges
then by the comparison test the larger
series the harmonic series here the one
where the corresponding terms are larger
that must also diverge and how do we do
that well let's just actually just take
these sums this is going to be so let me
write it so s is going to be equal to
one
plus
one-half
one-fourth plus one-fourth what's that
what's two-fourths or
one-half
i think you see what's going on here
this is exciting what's one-eighth plus
one-eighth plus one-eighth plus
one-eighth well that's four-eighths or
one-half what's 1 16 plus 1 16 and we're
going to go all the way until we get to
one although we're going to have eight
of these well that's going to be 8 16
or
one half
one half
and then you're going to have 16 130
seconds or one half and so
we're essentially just going to be
adding one half
and we start with one we just keep
adding one plus one half plus one half
plus one half plus one half well this is
clearly going to be equal to or this is
going to this is unbounded this is you
could say that this is equal to infinity
this is equal to infinity or another way
to think about it is s clearly diverges
s
clearly
diverges
and since s is i guess we could say each
of its corresponding terms or each of
its terms are smaller than the
corresponding terms in the harmonic
series we can then say that the harmonic
series diverges
harmonic
series
diverges
diverges there's no way that this thing
over here can converge if this thing is
each of its corresponding terms are
smaller and you could even think of this
kind of the sum as being smaller but
this sum goes to infinity so this one
must also go to infinity anyway
hopefully you found that as interesting
as as i did